and now
back to crustacean crime theater i mean
crustacean crime is all right i
personally prefer crustacean svu
these maritime flags don't make any
sense the letters spell out ri
unknown uk or ash 716 depending on the
code you use
neither which has any obvious meaning
when this clearly could have been a fun
place for an easter egg my point is
we're only 10 seconds into the episode
and i've done an hour's worth of
research on maritime flag codes so
there's no way any of us are getting out
of this without a since
the entire plot of this episode of
crustacean crime theater took 15 seconds
i'm not saying our attention spans won't
ever get so bad the tv will be like this
i'm just saying it hasn't happened by
this point and it can't be tick-tock
because that wasn't invented yet
and isn't on regular tv and this is
underwater oh that's where i
rent me pickles from how exactly does
one rent pickles
are you renting the barrel too well no
then you bought it no then isn't that
stealing
legalism and for those who think we're
legalists and how we give out our sins
i'm gonna make this worth five sins for
absolutely zero reasons other than to
prove we aren't
and sandy's hedge clippers why is no one
questioning how patrick knows that the
hedge clippers are sandy's
these are just generic looking hedge
clippers so the fact that he knows for a
fact they belong to sandy is a little
creepy
yes it's a shame that patrick has no
money for a balloon but it's fascinating
that he has a sock puppet in each of his
pockets
way to be prepared patrick you never
know when someone will need a puppet
starfish reproduce by releasing their
sperm and eggs into the ocean to unite
and develop
outside of the body and therefore do not
have belly buttons with which to store
paper clips
spongebob i want a balloon really really
badly
kids follow me
this is a sin for me sending a dozen or
so these episodes and forgetting to take
drugs beforehand
every damn time or have i taken the
drugs and not realized it and
why does it smell like purple in here
balloons never have been
and never will be this
the balloon exciting then we can go to
the beach with the balloon
these options balloon out of control for
some time we love
borrowing the us economy
even though it's only for a second this
shouldn't work at all so
this works we've gotta move fast and
cover our tracks
i'm on it spongebob i'm not sure which
spongebob staple to sin the conveniently
appearing paint or the fact that it
wouldn't work this way underwater
so just like my guidance counselor
suggested when i was figuring out
whether to take the act or sat i'm doing
both
even though neither really matters we're
gonna have to travel lighter but
spongebob had no issue carrying the
belongings he packed so why did he leave
them behind
also how did patrick get his house this
far out of town to begin with
hey if we're underwater how could there
be a
oh sure when patrick says that the show
listens but the second we bring it up
we're
taking a cartoon too seriously or
ruining childhoods or
deserve a porcupine enema no more
getting mail it's crazy to think that
this may be the line of dialogue that
has aged the poorest from any spongebob
episode
and all that running is good for your
buns and thighs right
yeah bunsen ties bodybuilder has a
central european accent cliche
also he's completely inappropriately
dressed for being located in the black
void of space
[Music]
funny image but starfish have neither
hair nor fur no
i'm nothing but a lot of talk you're the
one with the sticky fingers
title of my sex tape look what i've got
rectangles
[Laughter]
after patrick burrows a tunnel through
the sand his face still has chocolate on
it but no sand stuck to said chocolate
and having been a kid a sandbox with
candy bar once or twice in my life
this is some bullsh using a chocolate
bar as a q-tip when it clearly says do
not insert into ear canal right on the
label
we have chocolate on patrick's mouth we
have no chocolate on patrick's mouth
wow a partially eaten donut and a cops
like donuts in at the same time
it's like a donuts hole inside a donuts
hole or something
my point is cops don't always eat donuts
but if they do they would never leave
one with only a single bite of it on the
counter
same thing we do every night pinky in a
plane
and over a rock and under a hill and
we're the whale i do not like green eggs
and ham
we're thieves
take a last look patrick we can never go
back
we have to go back kate
happy birthday well sir you were a
cowardly son of a [ __ ]
you just shot an unarmed man well he
should have harmed himself
he's gonna decorate his saloon with my
friend